oh wait what's this one god this is so
hard by praedyth okay it hurts so much
right now hi I'm Matthew Francis I'm a
tasty producer and I've been cooking in
a professional kitchen since I was 15 I
graduated with honors and a bachelor's
degree from The Culinary Institute of
America and I've worked in multiple
restaurants a hotel and competed in
cooking competitions all across the
country Wow
and I'm Ryan so what are we doing today
today we're gonna see if I can talk you
through this difficult recipe with only
verbal instruction I'll be in a separate
room where I'll be able to monitor your
actions and only be able to help you
through a headset okay
what is the dish today I'm going to show
you how to make pate uncrewed pate on
crew is a classic French recipe of
heavily seasoned meat mixed with
colorful garnishes stuffed into a crispy
pastry crust it is definitely a
challenging dish because there is so
many steps involved every pate on fruit
is a bit different but no matter what it
has to be a beautiful show-stopping
centerpiece oh my god do you think I can
make this yes I think it'll not be easy
it'll be a challenge but I believe in
you and we're gonna learn so it's all
worth it right right yeah let's do it
okay Ryan you ready yes near you you
should see a food processor somewhere
around like maybe it's near the wall no
to your left Ryan really doesn't have
that much experience when it comes to
cooking but he's here to have fun and
he's here to learn enough of important
oh this this guy yeah processor yeah
it's a spice grinder no no a there
should be a bigger food processor okay
this is going off to a great start when
he said Patti uncrewed I don't know what
that means
but you know context clues pate is like
wet meat and then crude like croutons so
I figure it's like okay so then what
you're gonna do is you're gonna add the
flour all of it
yes careful not to spill too much I
never spill
Oh God be careful you can do this okay I
believe in you of course of course I can
okay salt put that in baking powder milk
okay no no like give it like a few
pauses just to mix it together so put
all the cold butter into the flour
yeah and just kind of break it up with
your hands and you're gonna pulse it
until it becomes kind of sandy sandy oh
man very sandy good job Ryan thank you
all right what's next okay now you're
gonna add in two eggs and then you lap
it over two egg yolks don't don't crack
it on an edge just crack it on the table
just on the table yeah like if you crack
it on the edge you're more likely to get
shards in your shards that would be
disastrous on the table here you learn
something new every day now you're gonna
put the lid on and pulse it again 100% I
can make it with Matthew so as long as I
ask enough questions and don't do
something stupid without asking first
yeah I can do it it's not gonna come
together anymore so I'll start adding
some of the milk oh oh maybe not all of
it let's try it try mixing it yeah I put
all the milk in at once so I hope that
doesn't mess up the dough because if it
does then that's the whole structural
integrity of the entire dish so nothing
I can do to the filling will save it so
I'm sure I just have my fingers crossed
at this point oh yeah that's definitely
a little bit too wet that's okay
every mistake is fixable it's inches a
little bit damp I want you to sprinkle
some flour over it and like maybe a
little on that round on the table and
then you're just going to knead it until
it's like if smooth and a little bit
drier smooth and dry and wait okay maybe
just put some flour on your hands too
and then do you know what I need uh
attempt it go for it I'll tell you okay
that'll work Ryan's hand placement with
this kneading is a little bit off but I
think he's still getting the gist of it
and it should work okay now what you're
gonna do is there should be like you've
used the knife around you and you're
gonna cut off one-third of it flatten
both into like a rectangle shape make it
make sure it looks good have a nice
rectangle okay
yeah looks like now you're good let's
stop let's stop touching it now get
plastic wrap and you're gonna wrap them
and put them in the fridge the next
thing we're gonna do is toast some
spices bay leave mushrooms
unidentified oh you're wrong what the
ones that you said are on identify I
think that's the coriander
oh wait what's this one those are close
oh are those smelly and aromatic yet
like the smell smell yeah I'm smelling
it all right I'm gonna put these in yes
you're gonna grind the spices now okay
and then just grind it until it's smooth
[Music]
well that's a sound are we sure we like
that sound okay I thought you're making
up panade what does that help pick in
the meat and keep it sticking together
panade meat stick together yeah okay
I've never heard of Pernod but again
context clues pawn bread
I knew that and then odd additional
ingredients add panade yeah not panade
so now I'm shaker shallot and you can
like peel it chop it I've never cut a
Charlotte before never know
Oh God okay when cooking a lot of the
things I don't even know the correct way
to describe it I just do it so having to
find a word to make Ryan understand it's
very hard the translation it's a little
bit difficult again don't like push down
like I got like a rocking motion you
want yeah all right cool put it in the--
yeah put it wherever you want and then
there's be some parsley around and
you're sort of chop a little bit of that
yeah Oh
lift your knife up I want to show you
the correct way to hold your knife put
your thumb around it like that and then
wrap your your index finger over the top
part of the blade it's like glue your
hand up a little bit so your finger
thumb thumb where it was great wait what
right there yep up a bit and then put
your index finger over the blade oh
there's a short part yeah you don't
touch the blade
yeah Matthews trying to coach me through
how to hold a knife proper
and I wasn't grasping it literally yeah
but you're pitching the knife pinching
oh my god there you go this yeah you
feel like you have better control now no
it does feel nice now you're gonna start
making the pate filling Ryan okay I
don't cook every day I cook maybe three
times a week the best thing I make
though is still my panna cotta I make a
I make a quite delectable panna cotta if
I do say so myself what consistency
should this be you want it to be a tacky
sticky texture take two of your fingers
and like put it into the meat and like
and it will fall off right oh yeah yeah
you want to beat it on high until it
will stick to your hand and not fall
okay so go to high
I've asked good I'm gonna try again yeah
try again see if it sticks better
overturn it awesome yeah great so now
you're gonna basically keep them meat in
the fridge and we're gonna move on to
rolling out the dough should I try and
touch it like not a lot yeah keep it
cold you want to work fast through this
don't roll up and down now roll like
left to right move the mold itself like
fold it over what we're gonna do is cut
out the corners that we don't need
because we want to have just be a
perfect amount of dough gotcha basically
line the knife up flush with the one of
the edges like go to one of the corners
no no no no go to one of the corners yep
and line the knife straight grain and go
like an extra like ten degree there so
it's like instead of cutting it at a 90
degree angle go at like a hundred degree
hundred degrees yeah geometry is hard I
cheated on my final in geometry in high
school I was caught and to take that
semester over again yes like that cut
right there and now if you're gonna cut
the triangle pieces like that on every
corner oh oh so just make a right angle
here on when you put it inside you want
the dough to overlap so instead of a
ninety degree angle you want more of
like you know a little bit more cute
goal can you gotcha geometry
you're gonna awesome job Ryan thank you
Woods of information you should be proud
of yourself you have a lovely voice oh
my god thank you and then bring the mold
back in the center and you're gonna
place that inside
okay now unfold everything
put it over the edges okay you should be
proud of yourself you're gonna great job
hey I'm so proud of myself
always and then really feel each of the
edges tough you don't want any of like
the meat juices or any of like any
liquid you pour in to leak out all right
this is important you really want to
pack it in there so there's no air
pockets I I have to reserve judgment
right now because I don't know how this
is gonna turn out go around the top and
press them together on the edge like
lift up the flaps and kind of cut them
off the hole is so that so it can vent
out air while baking and just fill it
with a speck later I'm gonna make a
large tree I can tell you're a natural
because for those giant pate as I
mentioned they often will do big trees
like that I always thought up until this
point right now that my patio and crew
is super unique now I feel like you know
how you think you're special but then
you realize that you're just like
everybody else just sort of like that
okay it looks worse than I wanted it to
Hey I nice look at this yeah look at
yours
look at mine so these both look great
but the moment of truth is when we
actually slice it open okay
so let me show you what it should look
like the meat if going as far as closely
edges is possible and we have the pieces
of garnish showing mm-hmm this is what
we want and I feel like yours will be
very close to that should we cut it open
yeah okay let's try yours I'm excited
this piece is gonna fall off yeah at the
top will always kind of just crumble
yeah yeah the collar looks great this is
incredible look how packed in it it's
really packed it looks great it
obviously isn't perfect but it's my
first time so I'm pretty proud of it
just excited to see how it tastes
today was incredibly fun I love to take
really challenging recipes that seem
like you can never do them and break it
down so it's simple and I'm glad that
Ryan proved today that anyone can make
dishes like this mmm good right so good
know next time at your next like cheese
party make a charcuterie board and make
this puppy and people will enjoy it no
doubt I like to experiment a lot with my
panna cotta to try different flavor
profiles mix it up it's part of the
sexiest food that there is
[Music]